back behind the net up top good work here by
the Penguins they roll the lines over flang
wrist shot deflected and they score Jake
gets on top the grease and Pittsburgh out
to their lead after a great shift just comes
down protects that puck moves it up high and
then you got those bodies to the net and
just make sokin uncomfortable getting his
personal space if you will and Chris L Tang
puts this is going short side now six goals
head to-head against Deus soken the most of
any current penguin great pass ahead here's gel
scores you cannot stop him breed up and
you're going to get Tristan jar grabbing
this Puck setting it up and then Jake
just coming from the left wing position
and just skating out to Center ice and
unaccounted for beautiful feed up to
him and how about that shot they're
booing him here on the island don't
they usually say something like yes yes yes
it's like no no no right now here's Malin
scores take that now all a sudden you get
the New York Islanders running all over the
place in these scene passes coming through Riley
Smith Chucks it right into the middle of the ice
here's Pon for Malin he'll try to pass better
off tonight Wang Wheels his way in for Malin
to flex it in and there it is fny Malin now all
alone he went to right to the back door and sat
there you see Mal right at the bottom of the
screen drops that pass goes back door plants
himself right in the blue paint Mario would
just kind of get lost on the weak side and he
kind of had his office in that regard here you
go uper two onone booting in for zah Horna he
scores redeems a horn is off the schneide and
everyone's feeling it tonight but you're going
to see one end here Chris L Tang headman this
and this is the speed I like from ping him he
can get going with those young legs and how
about that once the once a defenseman goes
down they're they're in second place in
the Metro for a reason and sure they're
not very happy with the way things have
gone in this game po it in a bom scores
get that puck for py first goal in the NHL
for valter ptin it Letang with the primary
so that's six assists or sorry yeah six
assists Now for Chris lat Tang lets this
thing rip and that's why I love him in that
power play Spot I know this was not a power
play but that's the area of the ice that he kind
of bumps in and out from here's a look at Chris
L does that put it into perspective all
listen what Chris L Tang we've pumped it
all night it's incredible what he's done
but I'm sorry Mario's done that four times